هذه شحنه من اصل 33 مليون طن من الحبوب
سمحت روسيا بتصديرها في يوليو عام 2022
فهل سيكون للقرار الروسي تاثير على الامن
الغذائي العالمي وحال نصف الكره الشمالي
يعيش فتره جني محاصيله من الحبوب روسيا
وبناء على هذا الوضع ترى ان التاثير سيكون
بسيطا
بيانات احدث تقرير لوزاره الزراعه
الامريكيه تعتبر ان انتاج اوكرانيا من
الحبوب تراجع الى النصف تقريبا خلال عامين
وان الوضع الحالي مختلف كليا عما كان عليه
سابقا
فتوقعات تقول ان انتاج اوكرانيا من الذره
خلال العام الحالي والمقبل قد يصل الى 25
مليون طن والقمح الى 17 مليونا ونصف مليون
طن مقابل 42 مليون طن من الذره
وثلاثه وثلاثين مليون طن من القمح تم
انتاجها عامي 2021 و 2022 اما الصادرات
فيتوقع ان يتم تصدير سته ملايين طن من
القمح وعشره ملايين طن من الذره وهو حجم
اقل مقارنه بالموسم السابق
وفق مراقبين الوضع الحالي اذا اقل توترا
واقل تاثيرا وتعليق اتفاقيه الحبوب اتى في
فتره هدوء تشهدها الاسواق كما ان احتياجات
العالم ستتضح بنهايه فتره الحصاد
لكن ماذا عن البدائل الخبراء تحدثوا عن ان
لدى روسيا حوالي 12 مليون ونصف مليون طن
من القمح الارخص في العالم موجود في
مخازنها وقابل للتصدير كذلك لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي بديل اخر يتمثل في ممرات تضامن
بري ونهريه تقوم بتسهيل الصادرات
الاوكرانيه عبر اوروبا وتقدر مؤسسه فارم
وهي مؤسسه بحثيه متخصصه في القضايا
الزراعيه العالميه ان نصف الصادرات
الاوكرانيه تمر حاليا عبر هذه الممرات لا
سيما عبر بولندا ورومانيا وهنا تتساءل
مؤسسه فارم عما اذا كان الاتحاد قادرا على
اعاده تصديرها